nicolas vidal bonjour bonjour olivier
heureux de vous retrouver ce matin dans
la matinale de rtl france alors une
lettre ouverte puis une tribune de
certains militaires la polémique enfle
dans le pays sur un sujet explosif
pourquoi selon vous à oui car c'est une
énorme épine dans le pied du
gouvernement et des manuels macron
olivier ce n'est pas une cenne seulement
bafouille un mais une lettre de généraux
à la retraite puis une tribune de
militaires and active qui viennent de
tomber lourdement sur l'opérant de viser
et de l'hôtel brienne du ministère des
armées
en réalité il apparaît au grand jour car
certains militaires viennent de franchir
le rubicon à deux reprises en moins de
dix jours alors ne vous méprenez pas
olivier run de moi l'idée de faire un
parallèle avec jules césar qui en 49
avant jésus-christ auréolé de sa
victoire sur les gaulois belliqueux mais
pas encore réfractaires à l'époque
s'apprêtait à conquérir le pouvoir
cette initiative n'est clairement pas
une tentative de putsch mais un cri
d'alarmé devant le délitement de la
france laissait entendre l'idée une
sédition ou non l'extrême droite dans
cette prise de parole elle me dit que
certains ont survolé ses textes avec une
morgue qui n'a d'égal que leur cécité et
on essaie de comprendre ce matin j'ai
entendu la mort de ce point de bascule
qui doit être prise au sérieux et
olivier alors nicolas pourquoi selon
vous certains membres du gouvernement
ont-ils condamné la forme est dénigré
également le fond des propos alors très
clairement les réactions d'indignation
sont totalement excessives
ils ont pour seul but finalement de
criminaliser les auteurs de cette prise
de parole
c'est une rhétorique bien connu de nos
jours en france avec cette doublette
infernal que son l'ostracisation et la
délégitimation on
avec des salves nourries d'éléments de
langage du côté de l'exécutif pour
contrecarrer cette alerte venant de ces
militaires on appelle cela commandant la
paix cela un tir de barrage horn on
déplaît la nièce panière une hache-- ya
florence parly non ce n'est pas le
retour de la 7ème compagnie composée de
putschiste mais la déligitimation et
l'art de ceux qui ne veulent pas voir
expliquant aussi que la seconde tribune
a été publiée en réponse à l'attitude on
va le dire un condescendant du
gouvernement dès la première lettre pour
les ans tire en espagne et russie avait
parlé de jeu si d'un quarteron de
généraux en charentaises qui appellent
au soulèvement il est certaine ces
généraux cosignataires cette tribune on
dit de florence parly la misère mais
qu'elle n'avait jamais eu seulement
obtenu un pistolet à bouchon olivier
mais la réalité c'est que l'elysée est
très contrariée par cette intrusion de
militaires d'un débat public car 58% des
français soutenaient la première lettre
et 73 % d'entre eux estiment que le pays
se délite dans un sondage harris
interactive l'elysée si friands des
sondages des enquêtes d'opinion semble
avoir oublié de regarder cela mercredi
donc ce type de valeurs actuelles
comptabilisé plus de 250 mille
signatures en soutien à cette nouvelle
tribu qui est devenu il faut dire une
véritable pétition nationale et à moins
de considérer que ce pays compte des
milliers le putschiste de facture ce qui
serait très très grave
il ya une abnégation formidable à ne pas
entendre et finement a laissé courir
mais vous savez olivier depuis les gilet
jaune depuis la réforme des retraites
les coudes n'est pas la qualité des deux
mairies certaine alors nicolas on a un
petit problème technique on a perdu
la liaison on va voir si on peut vous
récupérez alors on vous récupère nicolas
quelles tournures pourrait prendre cette
situation selon vous dans les prochaines
semaines alors désolé pour ce même
technique on ne sait jamais c'est la
grande muette à celle qui nous dit rien
et qui protège notre intégrité nationale
nos frontières et nous
valeur elle ne prend pas part au débat
public il fait encore moins de politique
et c'est là son depuis 61 ans le pouce
d'alger la larme et finalement respecter
son silence république
mais avec cette nouvelle éruption d'un
débat public le gouvernement se devait
se poser les bonnes questions plutôt que
d'admirer les loopings de florence parly
alors que peux tu y arrives à la france
dans les prochains mois la question a le
mérite d'être posée car le débat de fond
que pose cette tribune n'a pas abordé
avait été abordé mais évacués et il est
question aujourd'hui à cette tribune
d'un possible effondrement de la france
on peut trouver cela excessive mais
entendu mais ne pas le crâne est déjà un
père il en soit aujourd'hui emmanuel
macron se retrouve face à un mur sur le
sujet la sécurité nationale qui a été
son angle mort depuis depuis le début de
son quinquennat
car tout et économique pour emmanuel
macron il voulait faire de la france une
start up mais la france est une nation
aujourd'hui qui affronte de graves
périls dans ce véritable chef d'état
pourrait nous préserver il ya alors qu
emmanuel macron alors une menue comme
pour une fois là sont katrina fasse tout
pour protéger son peuple et sa sécurité
car ne défendra pas la france avec des
tweets des larmes des hommages et cette
fumisterie qu'est la souveraineté
européenne élaborer des impôts space
rompait merci beaucoup
nicolas vidal un édito à retrouver sur
les réseaux sociaux
et on retrouve jeudi prochain dans la
matinale